bonjour à tous nous avons le plaisir
d'avoir parmi nous gérard cherpion qui
est député des vosges et secrétaire
national en charge du travail et de
l'emploi chez les républicains qui nous
fera un petit compte rendu de la journée
de travail sur le travail et de la
consultation qui a été faite auprès de
nos adhérents
mais tout d'abord un petit poids d'un
jeune da avec aujourd'hui à 14h30
nicolas sarkozy qui va rencontrer le
président du ghana
monsieur john dramani mahama demain
mardi 6 octobre à 18 heures aura lieu le
bureau politique mercredi 7 octobre à 11
heures réunion autour de nicolas sarkozy
des chefs de file républicains aux
élections répondent les régions aux
élections régionales à 17h la commission
exécutive et à 19 heures le rendez vous
du projet l'initiative d'eric woerth qui
sera animée par arnaud robinet
secrétaire nationale à la santé sur le
thème le numérique levier de la
modernisation de notre système de santé
jeudi 8 octobre après midi nicolas
sarkozy se rendra à béziers pour une
réunion publique après avoir fait un
déplacement sur le terrain et samedi
dans cette maison aura lieu les états
généraux de la fédération les
républicains de paris avec des discours
de françois fillon ii
du goujon président de la fédération de
nathalie kosciusko morizet et de nicolas
sarkozy voilà pour l'agenda
alors ce week end donc et c'est terrible
aux événements dans le sud de la france
et avant de poursuivre ce point presse
nous tenons à rendre hommage aux
victimes et à leurs familles et nous
tenons à leur faire part de notre
soutien et notre solidarité
nicolas sarkozy a appelé christian
estrosi eric ciotti david lisnard maire
de cannes ce week-end pour pour pour
leur faire part de son soutien de sa
solidarité et avoir de plus amples
informations sur la situation sur sur
sur le terrain aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de place pour la polémique nos pensées
sont vraiment pour les victimes leurs
familles et l'état de catastrophe
naturelle ou demandant à ce qu'il soit
décrétée au plus vite pour apporter du
soutien toutes ces communes qui sont
touchés de manière très forte et qui
doivent réagir au plus vite puisque les
conséquences sont humaines elles sont
également économiques
c'est au référendum enfin la
consultation qui a eu lieu jeudi et
vendredi dernier sur la réforme du code
du travail gérard cherpion
oui merci donc nous avons une journée de
métier de travail mercredi sur la
refonte du code du travail et donc il ya
eu une bonne participation et trois
tables rondes très très intéressante et
comme l'a souhaité notre président il y
a eu une consultation de l'ensemble de
nos militants et une consultation qui a
été très importante puisque la première
consultation ces migrations avait
recueilli 53 milles
on sonne avant plus de plus de 42 mille
sur cette consultation qui a eu aussi
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus technique et
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus précises en
termes de projets ce projet a été avait
été présenté par par notre président est
ensuite suivie d'une d'une visite a pas
d eau ou gelé avec eric woerth
accompagné ses tenues ensuite une table
ronde avec des chefs d'entreprise qui
nous ont qui ont validé et finalement l
ensemble des propositions qui ont été
qui ont été faites et je veux dire que
cette consultation que nous avons nous
réalisons c'est véritablement une
consultation de de ce que souhaite
finalement les français puisque c'est
une consultation sur la première
priorité qui à celle des français
l'emploi c'est quand même très différent
de d'autres consultations je pense en
particulier à la consultation des
socialistes qui essaye de se retrouver
je ne sais comment ou de montrer leur
différence surtout d'étaler leur
différence finalement en un jour et sur
une consultation qui n'intéresse
finalement personne en dehors de en
dehors d'eux mêmes les résultats de
cette de cette consultation
il y avait donc neuf questions sur le
code du travail sur les droits
fondamentaux soit il vous recentrer le
fondamentaux des travailleurs ou est
renvoyé à l'entreprise essentiel du
dialogue social la réponse est très
claire elle est très favorable à plus de
92 12 92% et je crois que effectivement
ça répond à une nécessité d'avoir un
code du travail qui ce qui soit un code
du travail socle et à partir de ce code
du travail socle sur lequel on ne doit
pas revenir sur les propos les choses
intangible je pense par exemple aux
drogues dures ces problèmes de problème
qu'est-ce qui doivent être ancrées dans
le dans le code
le reste doit plutôt être de la
convention ou du la convention et du
contrat et l'a finalement une bonne
réponse qui va tout à fait dans ce sens
la deuxième question était
considérez-vous le premier rôle du code
du travail de favoriser l'accès à
l'emploi
il faut voir aujourd'hui que le code du
travail favorise ceux qui sont dans
l'emploi la terrorise protège ceux qui
sont dans l'emploi et finalement exclu
ceux qui ne sont pas dans l'emploi les
empêche finalement d'accéder d'accéder à
l'emploi et l'objectif étant
effectivement 2 da vers c'est aussi cela
est de dire doivent protéger bien
évidemment ceux qui sont dans
l'entreprise mais il doit aussi
permettre à ceux qui sont hors de
l'entreprise d'y accéder le niveau le
plus partisan du dialogue social et de
évidemment et l'entreprise ça a été très
clairement très clairement exprimée par
tous à la fois par notre président
également
et là une petite nuance est
effectivement c'est l'entreprise à la
branche professionnelle il y a un
cerveau un certain nombre de nos de nos
militants de nos huit militants il y a
effectivement cette possibilité de voir
la branche professionnelle je crois que
la branche professionnelle doit
effectivement intervenir mais par
substitution en cas où l'entreprise ne
ne le ferai pas et pour refonder cette
démocratie sociale les électeurs sont
favorables à ce que l'on supprime la le
monopole syndical de présentation au
premier tour des élections
professionnelles et en cas de blocage
d'échec des négociations ils ont une
considère qu'il ya nécessité très forte
de recourir au référendum
là encore c'est aussi ça fait partie de
la volonté que celle des républicains de
donner la parole à l'ensemble des
l'ensemble des personnes qu'ils soient
dans l'entreprise qu'ils soient dans la
vie publique et ça va tout à fait dans
notre dans l'esprit et vous d'accord
pour les entreprises puissent avoir la
liberté de sortir des 35 heures on a oui
à 4 près de 97%
je pense que c'est important et ça a été
très bien expliqué et c'est d'ailleurs
été très bien expliqué également par
notre président 35 heures c'est par est
pas une obligation mais ce les
entreprises qui veulent rester à 35
heures peuvent le rester
celles qui veulent travailler à 36
heures et bien travail à 36 heures
payées 36 il ya ce moment là on les
autres les heures supplémentaires se
déclenchent après 37 eur et payé 37 etc
on peut effectivement trouver trouver
une solution qui permette une une
souplesse et une adaptation nos
entreprises à la fois la conjoncture et
aux marchés faut-il assouplir de
licenciement économique notamment au
motif de réorganisation de l'entreprise
là aussi il ya une 85 % de oui je pense
que là encore aujourd'hui pour les
licenciements sont réservés à des cas où
l'entreprise est un très grand en grande
difficulté voire en très grande
difficulté le
ce que finalement il est souvent il est
souvent trop tard et je pense qu'il faut
effectivement avoir ses possibilités de
recourir aux licenciements mais pour
autant il faut également que ce
licenciement soit aussi j'veux dire
codifiée au départ dans le dans le
contrat de travail dès l'instant où il
est signé parce qu'on sache les uns et
les autres aussi bien le salarié que
l'employeur ce qu'il va devoir se passer
s'ils se doit si de ce devait arriver je
rappelle que je connais très peu de
chefs d'entreprises qui licencient par
plaisir
faut-il supprimer les seuils sociaux
dans les entreprises en dessous de 50
salariés
là aussi est là aussi on a oui à 89% ça
rejoint une proposition qui est la nôtre
de supprimer les seuils jusqu'à jusqu'à
100 je pense que c'est nécessaire on a
besoin de cette cette souplesse de cette
de cette liberté
et je rappelle qu'il ya des seuils
intermédiaire pour un tas de choses pour
un seul exemple vous avez un seuil à 25
soit ya 25 c pour la demande de cantine
dans les entreprises il faut le savoir
mais énormément de seuil comme ceci et
puis faut-il repenser les relations
entre les entreprises administrations en
particulier à la fois l'inspection du
travail mais aussi le problème du rsiq
est un véritable problème pour
introduire un principe de confiance
opposants à la fois sur le conseil et la
conciliation plutôt que sur la sanction
automatique l'objet c'est effectivement
qu'il y ait de la part de la part de
l'administration
une réponse qui soit une réponse d'abord
de conseil une réponse à dire préventive
mais qu'il ya aussi de la part de
l'entreprise la possibilité de faire
appel à l'administration pour avoir une
réponse c'est le rescrit social qui me
paraît nécessaire comme il existe un
esprit fiscale doit y avoir un rescrit
social qui oblige l'administration à
répondre aux entreprises voilà donc les
résultats de ceux de cette consultation
qui sont très finalement très conforme à
ce que il a été discuté lors dès lors
des tables rondes et qui va également
dans le sens de ce que le président
avait présenté la veille
très bien merci jacques dans l'actualité
cette semaine également c
la mobilisation des médecins contre la
loi touraine les républicains
soutiennent avec force le mouvement des
médecins
d'ailleurs nicolas sarkozy a eu
l'occasion à plusieurs reprises de
rappeler notre opposition à la loi tout
run à la loi touraine et notamment la
mise en place du tiers payant généralisé
effet les plus modestes des français ont
déjà accès au tiers payant et le fait de
la générale la généralisation et bien
portrait un grand coup à la médecine
libérale
ce serait une incitation à la sueur com
- à la surconsommation
le médecin deviendrait finalement le
client de l'assurance maladie avec des
conséquences dans l'avenir c'est à dire
que le gouvernement ne s'arrêtera pas là
une fois que les médecins de notre pays
serait uniquement des clients de
l'assurance maladie et bien on peut
s'attendre à ce que l'administration
continue à avancer et entraîner que les
patients soient obligés d'aller voir tel
ou tel médecin avec un certain nombre de
zonage et donc la mise en place d'une
véritable carte médicale
nous sommes en train d'assister avec la
loi touraine et bien à une vraie
étatisation de la médecine et à terme la
disparition de la médecine de la
médecine libérale telle que nous la
connaissons aujourd'hui s'aperçoit que
d'ailleurs sur un certain nombre de
sujets dans le cadre d'un certain nombre
de professions les socialistes veulent
mettre les professions libérales sous
coupe réglée avec une volonté affichée
de casser les professions libérales et
les indépendants on l'a vu récemment
avec la loi macron et comment cette loi
avait pour objectif de casser les
professions juridiques
notamment la profession notariale et
donc on s'aperçoit que ne s'arrêteront
pas en si bon chemin et bien aujourd'hui
ce sont les professions médicales qui
sont dans le collimateur du gouvernement
en effet l'autre risque sur sur la
médecine libérale c'est que la
généralisation du tiers payant on peut
pousser à la surconsommation médicale et
à l'heure où l'assurance maladie est
quand même dans une situation délicate
il faut il faut se prévaloir contre ce
risque là et contre comme le disait
sébastien l'étatisation voir la
fonctionnarisation des médecins libéraux
alors dimanche donc les élections au
portugal on va faire un petit point sur
ce sujet c'est la victoire d'un parti a
mis un parti qui a eu le courage de
réformer le portugal et le courage et le
sens de la responsabilité responsabilité
du ps d amener les portugais a renouvelé
leur confiance au gouvernement donc on
voit bien que lorsque des réformes
courageuses sont portés il y a des
résultats le pays se redresse et les
portugais renouvellent leur confiance à
ce alors à leur équipe gouvernementale
et nous saluons donc nos amis portugais
qui sont sur la voie du redressement
on va passer un petit complément
ce parti est un vrai partenaire des
républicains dans le cadre du ppe au
parlement européen donc sommes en
constant dialogue avec ses partenaires
et puis on s'aperçoit que quand un pays
est capable de prendre un gouvernement
est capable de prendre des mesures
courageuses lydia l'a dit le pays se
redresse mais pour être plus précis on
s'aperçoit que le chômage diminue et que
la croissance repart au portugal et donc
finalement on s'aperçoit que le
gouvernement portugais le premier
ministre monsieur passos coelho et bien
a fait tout ce que tout ce qu'il fallait
et tout ce que
françois hollande n'a pas fait pour
notre pays et donc peut-être que
françois hollande et le gouvernement
seraient bien inspirés de regarder ce
qui a été fait au portugal puisque la
france est le mauvais élève de la classe
européenne
partout ailleurs le chômage diminue
partout ailleurs la croissance est
supérieure à la nôtre il faut que le
gouvernement se ressaisisse que françois
hollande se ressaisisse il l'avait une
occasion de le faire avec le projet de
budget qui a été présenté en conseil des
ministres la semaine dernière et on
s'aperçoit que encore une fois
et bien c'est une occasion manquée un
symbole depuis dix ans plus de dix ans
le nombre de fonctionnaires dans notre
pays était en diminution notamment avec
l'action très volontariste de nicolas
sarkozy de ne pas remplacer un
fonctionnaire sur deux qui partait à la
retraite est bien dans le budget pour
notre pays de 2016
eh bien nous avons le nombre de
fonctionnaires qui va augmenter d'un peu
plus de 8000 et c'est vraiment un
mauvais signal des choix gouvernementaux
qui ont été faits et notamment vis-à-vis
de l'union européenne puisque ce n'est
pas comme ça que nous allons sous la
barre des 3% de déficit